what's up reject nation of Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey contact fluid or tears you
decide emotional or physical we're gonna
watch from cinemasins today everything
wrong with jaws oh boy damn Murrells
favorite movie one of the best movies of
all time this is a topper war tear video
request from home boy Jason Dolan great
friend of ours hooked up the camera with
us the one that we are filming on right
now so anything he asks for every two to
three questions we say yes to let's get
to it
holy what's wrong with us we will remove
five sins because we've total [ __ ]
for tackling this movie this is the most
confusing way of stacking actors names
basically ever Robert growing Shawn
Richard shudder try this myself but the
inspires tons of horror movies where a
woman's skinny dips and guy for whatever
reason can't go into the water with her
sigh sharks can play with their food
[Music]
beneath the shark doesn't seem hungry so
much as it seems like a Price is Right
contestant plate link up this shark not
like eat her legs or anything yet just
give her a ride around the ocean for a
bit it's kind of a dick shark is this I
know a lot of holes involved but since
when does chasing on naked chick cause
sudden passing out also is going on here
a duster to dish scrubbers three weirdly
small plastic spoons and a couple of
keys all hanging from a cookie at least
seven months ago and this medical
examiner has been around God knows how
long but it feels like this is the first
time these two ever been told the town's
life blood comes from summer tourism and
what about declaring this a shark attack
and the most naive way possible as if
there wouldn't be resistance and
cover-ups from the mayor and business
owners yes this mater guy is actually
wearing a suit with a million tiny
weight anchor something that's good
costuming sound bad hat blue the other
Natalie inspires Bryan Singer director
of movies like Superman Returns and Jack
the giant slayer nothing else mhmmm all
these tasty legs just dangling around in
the water for me to eat but i shall go
after the kid on the raft his mom will
be the most pissed
look no doubt there would be business
owners and politicians who would deny
the fact of a shark out in the one but
they weren't to deaths including one
that happened right in front of a
hundred people I mean Jesus
this is stupidity that only happens in
movies and real life I guess damn for
real life and sins literal fingernails
on a chalkboard to get attention as
opposed to half a dozen other better
ways to get attention to the crown of
roughly twenty four people also I know
positron or can be annoying but there's
no way this sound pierced all the sound
of the dumb people arguing there's no
shark and there totally is one when we
take a look at the shot just before
Quinn starts scratching the chalkboard
it doesn't appear he's drawn that crude
picture of a shark eating a child yet
and he doesn't seem to be anywhere in
the background but aberrated here use
the blue Network ah continuity
spreadsheet chocolate-covered chalkboard
immediately use it the same man to show
his mouth thereby assuring him so much I
know Ruby checks out every book that an
overeager prop master onion library
would lend it and he didn't even check
out the book what the pictures of the
weird sacrifices like everyone else in
Homer movies does this kid is as scared
as you say he is I highly doubt he'd get
that close to the water either flash
bullish an amazing after all these
people come to the island to hunt down
the shark and the media frenzy that
occurs that people don't decide not to
go to having you this summer no matter
what happens I mean publicity wise this
town is already lots of stupid and drunk
people are driving their attack with
boats in the water are looking for a
man-eating shark and somehow there are
no deaths or injuries
[Music]
I'm not sure if you can hear it but some
guy what are these folks just ask what
eight thousand dollars divided by four
is and that guy is definitely not trying
to be out here because it was terrible
math skills but because he waited until
now to even ask this this batch of John
was made with strawberries premature
celebration that's the reason why no one
wearing this suit shirt time
accommodation should ever utter these
words honestly no idea how the sheriff
doesn't commit seppuku after this kind
of public indictment they caught a shark
not the shark not the shark killed
Watkins by the way did Chrissy's family
ever show up to ask about her she was
pretty young and probably a family ah
look II just want those mystical fairies
that show up at parties beckoning guys
just go naked with them I'm the chief
employees America Louisiana license
plate does not prove the shark came from
southern waters last time I checked
people of all sorts of states drug their
cars into other states well so this
really did swallow this license plate in
southern waters and then went north how
did it not expel this thing one way or
the other during the time it took to get
to Emma D I mean yeah this isn't the
shark come on the man of science some of
these are bad deductions that makes a
lot of sense Hooper would be excellent
at citizens man-eating shark helpfully
leaves behind a tooth so Hooper can find
it and know for sure he's still out
there though he's hoping Hooper will
slip a dollar into his bill of a night
man you scared the dead guy for five
seconds and then you react and drop all
your I mean it would have made sense if
it happens right here but you looked at
it for hours before dropping the
evidence this guy believes that two
qualified people would bother to tell
him the shark still out there with
absolutely no motive to lie about it and
even if the mayor saw this tooth would
that even make a difference and this guy
still have anchors sewn into his suit my
god those proportions are correct love
to prove that when you get your name
into the National Geographic yeah but
you know that gets his name in there if
he proves the shark is there not by
making up a story so he can kill the
whole town's tourism industry let's all
those beaches won't be open for this
weekend it is now officially astounding
that Brody doesn't do more at this point
call the Coast Guard or the national
media yeah he might be out of a job here
in Amity but does he really need this
job
can he find some other sleepy town to
share one thing I've always wondered if
these [ __ ]
so now I'm not heard about the shark
attacks it's one thing for the Talon to
fight over keeping the beaches open but
the real problem should be after one or
two shark attacks absolutely no one
would be coming to these beaches
NTD one family Braves the waters and
everyone that was scared before decides
to go in without trepidation Steven
Spielberg directs his ass off so much in
this movie I nearly missed the part
where he throws put the phone in our
faces there's a cut here ha seriously
how did these kids not get shot even a
little bit after 10 seconds of
contemplation these people finally
realize that these kids are not a shark
shark looks out with the hoax just
before we attack so that this will seem
I concur or the probable scenario the
hero son falls into the shark water and
all I can think about is Mary Jane
Watson I think that means a sinner - is
it over you may not have heard it but
someone's yelling
does anybody have a gun amazingly this
is America and know it does well it'll
be a miracle the days you could smoke in
a most oh wait a minute what am I saying
let's go further even excessive brother
placement is a new concept please
consult Demonte camels and Hinds
that's some nice boar tattling the hell
ooh nice poor shadow
this will be a spectacular when it comes
to suspense virtually nothing of gnome
happens in the scene but the sin kinda
refused to put me with a stick like it
usually does when it's time to write
something it's setting things up for
later it's basically done under the
title of the movie the new wealthy
college boys don't have the education
enough to admit you're wrong
yeah that's really neat smart people Wow
good thing this shark doesn't show up
much in the movie because it looks fake
I wonder if they've been to do that
because we have to say Brodie
you're in a Spielberg film at a time
we're on transitions were oddly than or
bubbly I got that piece we got that feed
movie steals the scar showing scene from
chasing Amy
so I read the shooting star is genuine
and not a digital effect but then
Spielberg would start digitally adding
them and seemingly every movie after
this making this one less special so
shooting star unintentionally inspires
filled with special different with so
few chances to actually sit sharp when
it surfaces want to attach a second
barrel to the herb room rope or have
even three the shark is plenty big
enough to take them down so what's with
this one at a time
and why don't we suddenly have children
running through a brewery music playing
during this scene goddamnit who drops
everything when he's down in the water
he had his eight-mile moment earlier now
here's where he's supposed to lay down
the sick rhymes about Conan's his
parents having a real good there but
that's cause things like this to explode
in movies I am Wu 50 that's actually
pretty low for most every cinemasins
I've ever seen oh wait there's more
[Music]
he's hit by the sandbox that's not a bad
fish and the odors and I am this means
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
named Bruce I think that was perhaps my
favorite part of the whole video not
sure why he wanted us to cover this one
specifically Jason because it's a
gauntlet throw you know what do you mean
it's like oh how do you take on jaws
it's it's it's one of the best films of
all time and it's one of the early can't
Titans of this little bubble of YouTube
that we live in you know Revere this
movie above all so to take it on as
fighting words man I hey there's
literally its innocence generally is
nitpick cinemasins has a very specific
point of view and opinion that you need
to be aware yeah it's like humorous the
whole point of them is usually crazy
amounts of nitpicking but usually even
like the nitpick ones they usually lend
themselves to a video or two that I'll
be like that's actually a very solid
point and did quite get that with this
one and I think they felt that too it's
pretty apparent by the fact that they
start this video off with negative five
seconds early right away showing oh yeah
we really can't find anything wrong with
this movie so yeah the most wrong thing
I can find that they pointed out that I
thought was good was the continuity
error Quint in the background with the
chalkboard and then like there's no
drawing of the shark that moment yeah
that's actually true like in terms of
editing it kind of doesn't make sense
when you really think about it in terms
of time gaps and usually in editing you
don't notice it was like I have Matt's
house I've seen jaws I've never noticed
that so that I appreciate it and then
sometimes they say stuff you're like
well like the guy at the beach you know
I totally believe that dude who's that
wasted could have easily knocked out
yeah matter how worried he was you know
it's happened to many guys it's so drunk
their ad doesn't matter how hot a girl
is they sometimes they knock out or
something like that oh yeah I can
believe that he totally missed that well
there are a lot of things that are like
very subjective that are pointed out
like you know the the mayor's suit and
I'm like well yes y'all about tourism
and this is a beach town of course it's
got anchors all
like it's not really something wrong
with this movie yeah just I guess you
don't like that choice or whatever the
thing about these videos I gotta be in
the right mood for cinemasins basically
but I do feel like they inevitably you
know you're throwing darts at a board
and inevitably some of them hit a target
for me where I'm like okay fair point
like sheriff Brody could have called in
some bigger entities to help me and then
the town's like why were the people of
the town's the regular folks so eager to
get in the water after this attack
happens still like we need to go to this
Beach specifically yeah no other Beach
why is it yeah that everyone's like you
got it use the dam that's like a fair
thing to wonder I don't think it in any
way destroys the functionality of the
movie and I did appreciate that they
took sins off during that one moment
about like nothing technically happens
in this one scene highlighted the
suspense and the fact that yet
technically nothing's happening it's
just waiting but it's so intense and so
I was like good on your cinemasins for
pulling the Technic lagus took like
eight sins off or ten yeah yeah it's
like watching an honest trailer for a
movie that is definitively pretty good
yeah you know and then you're like okay
I'll give you a couple fair nitpicks and
the rest is just fun I guess the
difference with something like an honest
trailers or even a screw rants pitch
meetings versus cinema sins and there
I've had my nights where I binge
cinemasins plenty of those nights
actually in the right yeah they're
always fun to watch I think though that
there's been like making fun of a movie
and then saying this is an error with
the movie yeah I think cinemasins
naturally gets flack for that and for
calling attention and being like this is
something that's wrong with the movie
because sin and when really that's not
they're not actually saying that they're
just doing their fun talent making witty
observation yes exactly
okay exactly so but it's easy for people
to take it as like we're talking about
the suit to do the inker suits a sin
it's something wrong like they're not
saying that it just kind of registers to
people as if it is yes yeah and I feel
like cinema sins as an entity could
overall
have a better articulation of what it's
actually doing because I feel like if
you look at the comments there is kind
of a general vibe you'll always see the
ones we're looking subjective half of
these are really nitpicky and I do think
there's gotta be like there's got to be
a better way to establish that it's this
specific channels voice point of view
taste and yeah that's right cuz like I
guess before I used to just think of
like oh this really believes that all
these things are wrong with this movie I
should be written different but I feel
like really behind the camera it is just
like whatever comes to mind I'd be
curious as to how they actually do write
these basically yeah but yeah there's
gotta be like a better opinion
disclaimers or anything
either way cinemasins put themselves in
the corner it's really hard to dislike
this movie do the Godfather next yes
isn't Kanan I got no fiction one here go
get money two minutes long oh boy oh
yeah well you know it's Tarantino I'm
sure Tarantino
alright guys well what did you think of
this cinemasins video make sure to
comment down below you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell Jason Dolan what
more can I say man you're kicking ass in
the business you got us into a cool
comic-con party you're doling out
scripts yes you are you don't even look
to me for approval obviously on the show
people from then you looked at me I
don't know I just want to see if I made
you smile and see now I know I didn't
get the approval well I'm gonna give you
an old-fashioned shout-out here I looked
up your name and now I get why you are
such a good person your name means
healer oh you're like Jesus Jesus man
he's just crystals Jason the healer well
I'll tell you man you've healed this
channel through so many trouble
sometimes not just with your awesome
pledge that you have just not gotten rid
of in the past couple years and all this
t-shirt we still have your [ __ ]
t-shirt yeah we've been up with you at
least three yeah since we've had your
t-shirt and we've never given it to get
we need to do is keep Jason's t-shirt on
us everywhere we go through you you're
not gay
shirt yeah we'll just send you pictures
of us doing things in the show laying
your deathbed will finally give you your
shirt yeah and then we won't heal you
mmm
yeah we've cigs Act there's no full
circle here we're done